according to the intelligence we have uh
just britain alone have about 400 to 450
known people fighting amongst the ranks
of isis
if even 10 percent of these people
survive
if i know abu bakr al-baghdadi he will
use these people
to attack united kingdom the
intervention of european or the western
allies
i don't see it happening but at least
they could do is to supply
some of the regional forces that are
fighting isis now
with ammunition with better weapons this
is the least they can do because if this
situation gets worse for us
believe me it's going to get worse for
the europeans as well isis the type of
weapons they have now they have
uh humvees armed humvees they have apcs
they have tanks in muscle they even have
helicopters that they put their hands on
from the iraqi army these are all u.s
weapons they have much better weapons
than we have
we are fighting with all russian weapons
against these guys what's your message
then to
the international community to the
americans to the british right now
they shouldn't just let this go away so
easily because
like i said this is not only a war
against the iraqi government and the
kurdish people here
this war will come back and bite them
in the us back in europe and
in the states so they should really
somehow get involved i'm not saying put
your military forces
on the ground but at least you could do
is uh have some sort of air strikes to
support
our forces and to help us with some
ammunition and weaponry
you